hi there Steve Kaufman this is kind of
an unscheduled impromptu video it's just
that as I follow events in Ukraine I'm
aware that today in the city of levive
and elsewhere in Ukraine they're holding
this day of learning English they're
trying to hold the largest-ever English
class in history and get it into the
book of the Guinness Book of Records and
of course it's a great way to promote
English and I'm putting a link to a news
report on it here in the description box
and you'll see that the American
ambassadors they're saying that you know
your crane is wants to be part of the
European a broader European community
and learning English is important and so
forth and so on and I have to say that
at some level even though English is
very useful as an international language
there's something about equating English
with being modern or with being European
that kind of grates on me there are many
languages in Europe German French
Italian Spanish you name it and learning
any of those languages is a way of being
more European or even to thai language
learning to a particular political
perspective I think is something that
grates on me so it just so happens that
while the Ukrainians are learning
English I'm in fact learning Ukrainian
today it's a rainy day in Vancouver and
I'm reading on link ebooks that i found
one is history of ukraine which i have
now been reading and i worked my way
through kiev kevin rose to you know the
princess of galicia and valina to the
rise of the of the Cossacks and stuff
and I at the same time I've got I found
a book on the history of of relief which
is where this event is taking place and
levive was this fast that in place that
was founded by vanilla and garlic or
whatever back in whenever 13th century
that was a third of the the ukrainian
city then the largest city in old city
subsequently through history changed
hands polish lithuanian blah blah blah i
ended up being part of the
austro-hungarian empire
and before the Second World War was a
50-percent polish should thirty percent
Jewish and twenty percent that made
roughly Ukrainian all of the surrounding
towns and suburbs and certainly you know
rural communities were Ukrainian and
it's now sort of the main you know
predominantly Ukrainian speaking city in
Ukraine all very interesting and I'm
accessing all of this through Ukrainian
so and then I'm going to say simonia vu
crania a group Ludi anima Heinze
organizer wat a nie be she rock and ice
cream movie historia la AE tumbled are
you say paso paso la sección yeah kiske
saath show viv chart a angliski and lee
school inglese como se shark na na na
bring coo sutures narrow p alley yeah
natok duma you minista it's a show with
chatty reasoning in Oz emek movie set
set set C dobre in an ethical Nellie che
angley's como vous allez resnick mogu da
soho say odna ya budo the chart a
ukraine's como voy a la chi thao kini
who Alec nehe electronic electronic nehe
Oh astoria a pro historia crane a pro
history lluvia y at so throb throb are
you a jealous is it rains como vo
attacking chineham muzu viv chart a move
oh ah Rosalita my as
a pro a pro 8am veliki trainee ucrania
papa Topo virginia